you
also wrote a blog post recently giving a
shout out to the new book
the block size wars
what is the block size what are the
block size wars
it's history it's importance it's uh
philosophical foundations
yeah i mean bitcoin at this point we
have our own civil wars
if you're wondering about how
politically intense it gets
it's currently not hot it's cold it's oh
yeah we're in a dayton right now
there's no tanks or missiles at least
not yet hopefully
it can get a little violent i guess i
think one of the bitcoin core developers
or
one of the participants in the in the
war got swatted at one point
what swatted means when someone does a
fight a fake
uh phone call saying that you're holding
someone hostage
at your house and the swat team goes
it's pretty scary
wow internet warfare tactic yeah but
uh the block size war i would say
effectively ended
um although we're definitely going to
have more
civil wars in bitcoin for sure but
basically the core argument was a
technical one on its surface but a very
deep political one at its core the
technical question is
how many megabytes should be in each
successive block
so satoshi basically installed a limit
of one megabyte per block
so we should backtrack there was no
limit
in the beginning and it seems like
satoshi
what is this 2000 the war started in
what 2017 or something like that
i don't know when the 15 was when the
you know
the battle cry what was the first battle
in the civil war
i don't remember but sort of satoshi i
don't know if you can comment it
on it like why did satoshi set the limit
to one megabyte all of a sudden
almost see secretively and in the
beginning
there was no limit whatsoever yeah i
mean we can get into
and people have spent thousands of hours
pouring over satoshi's writings to find
you know which side satoshi was on and
you can find
like any textual exegesis you can find
evidence
for either side right but uh yeah i mean
effectively when bitcoin was launched
there was a block size because
if you made a block over a certain size
with the first edition of the code
it would have crashed nodes but then
yeah in 2010 satoshi added the one
megabyte limit
in a covert way with no comments or
anything
and uh that's stock basically and uh
and then bitcoin blocks filled up and
people that had been socialized into
this vision of bitcoin
as an effectively free transactional
network or like why
pay a transaction fee if you're not at
congestion
if the block isn't full the miner will
mine your transaction for free
right um people that had been brought up
in that
status quo from 2009 to kind of 2015
they noticed the blacks started to fill
up and like okay well let's just remove
this arbitrary limit
right what what could possibly be the
harm right and then
a whole other faction said no you need
to
cap the data throughput of the system
because if you increase it it's going to
be highly exclusionary
and ultimately regular folks are not
going to be able to run a full node
so there's a fixed number this is a
fixed frequency of blocks
and so if you want to increase the
number of transactions
per second you want to increase the size
of the block so huge blocks
allow you to shove in a lot of
transactions right small blocks don't so
that's what you mean like constraining
the system
so what's the benefit of a small block
size where transactions
uh when you can squeeze in only a small
number of transactions
and what's the benefit of a huge block
size where you can squeeze in a lot of
transactions
well it really comes down to the way you
think about the system
so a lot of people wanted bitcoin to be
visa scale
so do you have blocks sufficiently large
that you could accommodate
a visa level scale of transactions so
which is many orders of magnitude more
transactions that's right i mean
preposterously larger in terms of data
throughput
then you know bitcoin offers up or at
least it used to 144 megabytes of space
per day
and your average transaction is 350
bytes
so you know you could add a push do
for 500 000 transactions a day which is
not many
so if you wanted to get to visa scale
you'd have to increase blocks
obnoxiously large the small blockers
claimed that this would
overwhelm the ability of any regular
person to ingest that
data and stay current at the you know
state of the ledger
to rebroadcast to replay all those
transactions to ensure that the protocol
rules were valid so basically
the small blocker contention is that you
eliminate the trustlessness
of the system by pushing a ton of data
through the system because
only one or two industrial heavy-duty
nodes
would ever be able to run the protocol
at that point
so by the way in the civil war the two
sides
as you as you're calling them the small
blocker and
the big blocker sides and so that's
takes us back to the uh the thing that
you mentioned that a regular computer
could be a node
and with a big with big blocks
that's no longer going to be the case so
just the number of transactions is going
to blow up
the size of the blockchain that every
full node has to store
and so then as opposed to a regular
mom and pop type of node you're going to
have to have
data centers so they're going to have to
be owned by
large organizations there's going to
have to be very few of them
and that's how you centralize the
control over this whole
uh operation so the big blocker
uh yes it allows you to be visa
and do a huge number of transactions but
it becomes centralized and the small
blocker is
you cannot actually do kind of merchant
style transactions
but you get the decentralized benefit
well i don't even think
the big blog approach would allow you to
be visa frankly
because there's effectively one node at
the visa network
right so you don't really need to
maintain this peer-to-peer architecture
at all
and the amount of data you have to push
through the network
to reach visa scale is a really
preposterous amount
i mean and we have now evidence for what
happens
when you try and scale up as a
blockchain and do 10 million
transactions a day which is still not
visa scale
right you know i've i've
you know seen what it's like to operate
those nodes and it's not pretty
so there are totally genuine computer
science
physical limits um because it's a
it's a broadcast network everyone has to
be aware of every transaction
and that model which gives you the
trustlessness the nice guarantees where
everyone's an equal peer on the network
everyone has audited the full history of
the transactions
that model falls apart under stress so
the small blocker vision is that
ultimately
you would scale in a layered approach
with the base layer transactions being
settlement style transactions
and you know payments happening at the
other layers basically
is that universally agreed upon or like
to a large degree agreed upon that the
small blockers have won in this
in this debate well where would you put
the current state of affairs
there was a wave of competing bitcoin
implementations
in starting in 2015 with bitcoin xt
um actually gavin anderson who was the
guy that satoshi handed the reins to
when satoshi left gavin supported this
large
block proposal uh and so that was that
didn't achieve consensus
and then there was bitcoin unlimited and
then
later on there was a genuine hard fork
where
the small blockers couldn't or the large
blockers couldn't push through their
proposals
on bitcoin itself so they just created a
competing version of bitcoin you know so
by the way
uh maybe you can comment on but sort of
hard fork versus a soft fork a hard fork
is
when it's not no longer compatible
what's the right way to put it
they can't operate on the same
blockchain they say with the same
protocol
yeah so there's a few ways to define
them and it's
pretty it gets controversial as well but
um
one one way to define it as a hard fork
is
a expansion of protocol rules and a soft
fork is a shrinking
of protocol rules that's an interesting
way to find it it's not very intuitive
so
i don't like that way um another way is
that a hard fork is backwards and
compatible whereas softwork is
in theory backwards compatible so in
august 2017 basically the large blockers
had had enough
and they said we're gonna hard fork
bitcoin we're gonna
create a clone an alternative version of
bitcoin
which has the same a shared history as
bitcoin itself
but you completely fork it and you
create a new future
and uh but you know everybody that had a
balance on bitcoin at the time
also had a balance on the alternative
coin bitcoin cash
and so that was really that's what's
called bitcoin cash is the hard fork
that was one of them there were more
actually i mean what what the heck is
bitcoin satoshi
uh satoshi's vision bsv bitcoin sv so
this is all talking about
increasing the max the limit of the
block size more and more and more
yeah that was one of the changes they
wanted to push through
uh but bsv was the fork of bitcoin cash
so
hard fork of bitcoin yeah so and so now
there's multiple big blocker
blockchains floating around it's like
what are your thoughts about them
well i was pretty popular sorry to
interrupt
uh are they popular i mean if you look
at the metrics they're not and
oh they they don't trade they i think
each trade below one percent of the
value of bitcoin
see so measuring popularity is like how
much they actually
oh value value frequency of trade oh no
no i mean
they they do like a fair number of
transactions but there's an there's no
way to know that that is genuine
or just contrived so you know ultimately
the true measure i think in my mind is
just
where the market prices these protocols
relative to bitcoin
uh because that's like a prediction
market if
if bitcoin cash was being priced at 50
of bitcoin
you could say the market has given it a
50
chance of unseating bitcoin right but
both bitcoin
cash and bitcoin sv which was a hard
fork from bitcoin cash itself
are well i believe at this point well
below one percent of the value of
bitcoin
and in the so in like the ranking of
different cryptocurrencies
what is it bitcoin ethereum is ethereum
in value
uh yes number two and then bitcoin cash
is somewhere
it's in the top five right but it's just
a fast drop off
you know i haven't checked lately but i
think it's it's reached kind of
morbidity
you know it doesn't really have much
traction
um the blocks aren't full so the whole
value proposition was
you know we will get all this merchant
adoption if we increase the block size
that just didn't materialize
in my view they had a flawed vision of
how adoption works
and what blockchain should optimize for
maybe maybe you get a bitcoin cash
supporter on the show they'll give you a
different answer
but yeah full disclosure you know have
my sympathies and
i think the small blockers won that
skirmish for sure
so at this time there's no merchant
adoption and so on so it's kind of
its vision the whole reason for
existence for at least for now hasn't
materialized
and so that's that's the indication is
possible that
well it's a sign that perhaps that's the
wrong way to accomplish the scalability
you